bonsoir jean christophe lagarde merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on viens de l'entendre olivier verrons
qui tombe détendre lynx ont dix ans des
nombreuses critiques d'ici demain soir
et mercredi il y aura une centaine
d'hôpitaux notamment qui offriront la
vaccination à leurs soignants ainsi
qu'aux soignante ville il y aura un
bilan au quotidien vaccination c'est une
réponse satisfaisante selon vous écoutez
d'abord il faut regarder où on est on a
échoué sur les masques on a été minable
sur les tests on est en train de se
planter sur la vaccination
à croire qu'il faut jamais changer une
équipe qui perd qui ait jamais changé
une stratégie qui échoue g hier publié
une vidéo qui montre mon exaspération
mais surtout celle des français qui ne
comprennent pas ce qu'on est en train de
faire depuis des mois nous vivons sur ce
virus depuis des mois nous attendant une
solution
le vaccin c'est la solution je comprends
et je respecte que des français ne
croient pas dans le vaccin etc
mais il ya 25 à 30 millions de français
qui attendent d'être vaccinées depuis
une dizaine de jours qu'on est censé
commencer à vacciner on a vacciné 500
personnes les allemands 200 milles
où est l'erreur l'erreur aller dans
l'administration sanitaire qui n'est pas
en capacité de faire nous annonce
l'accélération y compris avec des
mesures absurdes par exemple de dire que
les médecins personnel médical de plus
de 50 ans on va pouvoir être vacciné à
bompas qui à 48 ans il risque pas de
transmettre le virus s'y risque pas
d'être à manger c'est absurde ce sont
ceux qui sont les plus exposés ceux à
qui on doit toujours un temps derniers
on les applaudit c'est aujourd'hui on
refuse de les vacciner selon leur âge ça
n'a pas de sens
de la même façon en france on complique
les choses à volonté pour protéger je ne
sais pas qui par exemple en nous
demandant d'aller faire une consultation
médicale avant la vaccination
aucun pays au monde demande ça aucun
médecin de france me demande ça vous
allez faire une consultation vous laisse
quelques jours après vous réfléchissez
mais enfin madame quand vous allez vous
faire vacciner vous retirer votre
chemise votre tailleur et que vous
présentez votre épaule pour vous faire
vacciner vous savez ce que vous allez
r et le vaccin étant la seule solution
contre le virus comme ça l'a été contre
la polio bélier contre le tétanos contre
toutes ces maladies qui ont disparu dans
notre pays eh bien les gens qui veulent
se faire vacciner doivent être libres de
le faire
je comprends encore une fois qu'ils les
gens qui ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner simplement ceux qui veulent le
faire aujourd'hui il ya un million de
doses dizaine mise de la santé et bah
donné un million de bourges et qu'on
aille invraisemblable d'ailleurs à quoi
pardonnez moi à quoi vous imputer cette
lenteur et ses débuts ratés au système
français on parle beaucoup de
l'administration le poids de
l'administration qui ressort une
nouvelle fois un manque
aulas de volonté une prudence comment
vous vous l'expliqué aujourd'hui
clairement d'abord par le fait que les
politiques ne dirige pas leur
administration
pardon de le dire mais enfin c'est au
président de la république pas
l'administration sanitaire qu'on m'a
donné le soin de protéger les français
deuxièmement parce que quand on entend
le gouvernement quand on entend ce
qu'ils sont censés organiser la
vaccination tous leurs discours sont
anxiogènes tous leurs discours
là où dans le monde entier on sa race le
vaccin enfants sans dire au delà on va
aller doucement va voir on va savoir
faut savoir soit il est dangereux il
faut pas le donner soi il n'est pas
dangereux il soit le donner si le monde
entier et nos amis et nos propres aux
autorités sanitaires considèrent qu'il
n'est pas dangereux
maintenant il faut vacciner massivement
rapidement y aller et on est en réalité
en france dans un système où le
gouvernement par trouille est sous la
coupe des anti vaccins et la stratégie
vaccinale effacée par le parlement comme
le souhaite par exemple damien abad
lr la stratégie vaccinale dons soit
organisé un débat doit être organisée
rapidement parlement avec un vote damien
bête qui propose un allègement des
procédures de consentement ça doit
passer par là côté je les ai procédé
proposé hier soir j'ai demandé au
président de la république d'arrêter
avec la consultation très vaccinale que
nous sommes les seuls à organiser de
faire en sorte qu' il n'y ait plus ce
délai de quatre jours parce que les
français sont pas des crétins ils savent
s'ils se faire vacciner ils n'ont pas
besoin de quatre jours de plus
on a toutes les informations sur les
vaccins
ya ceux qui ne veulent pas très bien
pour eux hier ceux qui en veulent déjà
permettront de le faire et puis comme je
vous le disais la stratégie vaccinale
édité par les anti vaccins par la
trouille cas l'exécutif des poursuites
judiciaires ou de je ne sais quoi mais
ça suffit ça suffit à un moment donné
expliqué que les soignants les
enseignants les personnes dans les ehpad
doivent pouvoir être vacciné et pour les
personnes dans les ehpad regarder ce
qu'on nous répondrons dire ah bah oui il
faut recueillir leur consentement à on
découvre maintenant mais ça fait trois
mois qu'on s'est créé un vaccin qui
arrive ça fait trois mois qu'on aurait
dû leur demander ce sont les personnes
les plus fragiles les plus vulnérables
celles qui ont le plus fort taux de
mortalité sur 65 mille morts ces vingt
mille personnes dans les ébats dans les
épaves
on aurait dû demander avant qu'on le
fait pas enfin il faut arrêter et moi je
demande au président de la république un
de diriger son administration 2-2 décidé
de libérer les collectivités locales les
régions les départements et les communes
pour qu'ils organisent la vaccination
puisque son administration sanitaire ne
sait pas le faire et doit passer par des
vaccinodromes comme en allemagne le
débat ait lieu maintes fois on se
souvient de l'échec de 2008 avec le h1n1
ce qu'on doit le faire en france
aujourd'hui clairement balade j'ai été
président de la commission d' enquête
sur ce qui s'est passé les chèques gelé
voulu j'ai déterminé
l'échec de la vaccination de 2010 sur le
chan disons les choses clairement ce qui
n'a pas fonctionné à l'époque c'est
qu'on n'a pas mis les médecins les
médecins généralistes les médecins de
ville
les pharmaciens dans la boucle
dès aujourd'hui les pharmaciens ils ont
droit de vous vacciner contre la grippe
il devrait pouvoir vous vacciner contre
le coc vide
les médecins généralistes sont ceux qui
connaissent votre famille vous un tc
dans vos allergies éventuelles
c'est à eux qu'il faut confier sa part
vaccineront peut-être qu'il faudra
organiser mais libérons les choses vous
savez pourquoi aujourd'hui on ne t'aime
pas au médecin de famille la possibilité
de le faire parce que le conditionnement
c'est à dire le nombre de vaccins par
dose pose problème ils sont parfaitement
capables d'organiser une deux trois
journées où ils ne reçoivent que des
patients qui veulent se faire vacciner
on leur donne le nombre de vaccins on ne
parie pas sur l'intelligence et jean
croix dans l'intelligence de
l'administration et bat l'administration
sanitaire elle échoue elle a échoué sur
les masques elle a échoué sur les tests
elle est en train d'échouer sur les
vaccins et c'est insupportable d'avoir
enfin ce qui permettrait de revivre
normalement de protéger des vies et que
et que nous ne soyons pas en situation
intellectuels politiques par des
décisions par monsieur le président la
république premier ministre par
messieurs les rangs de dire écoutez ça
suffit vos protections et votre
centralisation débile on va faire
confiance aux acteurs de terrain aux
médecins aux pharmaciens ont commune aux
régions aux départements et on va
laisser vacciner
la seule question qui vaille c'est
pourquoi avec le même vaccin les mêmes
contraintes les mêmes difficultés la
même maladie la france est la dernière
de la classe de l'europe et du monde
nous devenons la risée du monde on a
acheté il sait très bien au niveau
européen des vaccins pour que personne
n'en manque et nous on a des vaccins
mais personne n'en a
merci jean christophe lagarde d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france